we have so far discussed the first step
involved in the construction of a
probabilistic model namely the
construction of a sample space which is
a description of the possible outcomes
of a probabilistic experiment we now
come to the second and much more
interesting part we need to specify
which outcomes are more likely to occur
and which ones are less likely to occur
and so on and we will do that by
assigning probabilities to the different
outcomes however as we try to do this
assignment we run into some kind of
difficulty which is the following
remember the previous experiments
involving a continuous sample space from
which was the unit square and in which
we throw a dart at random and record the
point that occurred in this experiment
what do you think is the probability of
a particular point let's say what is the
probability that my target my dart hits
exactly the center of this square
well this probability would be
essentially zero hitting the center
exactly with infinite precision should
be zero and so it's natural that in such
a continuous model any individual point
should have a zero probability for this
reason instead of assigning
probabilities to individual points we
will instead assign probabilities to
whole sets that is two subsets of the
sample space so here we have our sample
space which is some abstract set Omega
here's a subset of the sample space call
it capital a we are going to assign a
probability to that subset a which we're
going to denote with this notation which
we read as the probability of set a so
probabilities will be a
signed two subsets and this will not
cause us difficulties in the continuous
case because even though individual
points would have zero probability if
you ask me what are the odds that my
dart falls in the upper half let's say
off of this diagram then that should be
a reasonable positive number so even
though individual outcomes may have zero
probabilities sets of outcomes in
general would be expected to have
positive probabilities so to coming back
we're going to assign probabilities to
the various subsets of the sample space
and here comes a piece of terminology
that a subset of the sample space is
called an event why is it called an
event because once we carry out the
experiment and we observe the outcome of
the experiment either this outcome is
inside the set a and in that case we say
that event a has occurred or the outcome
falls outside the set a in which case we
say that event a did not occur now we
want to move on and describe certain
rules the rules of the game in
probabilistic models which are basically
the rules that these probabilities
should satisfy they shouldn't be
completely arbitrary first by convention
probabilities are always given in a
range between 0 & 1
intuitively zero probability means that
we believe that something practically
cannot happen and probability of one
means that we're practically certain
that that an event of interest is going
to happen so we want to specify rules of
this kind for probabilities these rules
that any probabilistic model should
satisfy are called the axioms of
probability theory and our first axiom
is a non negativity axiom namely
probabilities will always be
non-negative numbers it's a reasonable
rule the second rule is that if the
subsets that we're looking at is
actually not a subset
but is the entire sample space Omega the
probability of it should always be equal
to one what does that mean we know that
the outcome is going to be an element of
the sample space this is the definition
of the sample space so we have absolute
certainty that our outcome is going to
be in Omega or in different language we
have absolute certainty that event Omega
is going to occur and we capture this
certainty by saying that the probability
of event Omega is equal to one these two
axioms are pretty simple and very
intuitive the more interesting axiom is
the next one that says something a
little more complicated before we
discuss that particular action a quick
reminder about set theoretic notation if
we have two sets let's say a set a and
another set another set B we use the
notation we use this particular notation
which we read as a intersection B to
refer to the collection of elements that
belong to both a and B so in this
picture the intersection of a and B is
this shaded set we use this notation
which we read as a union B to refer to
the set of elements that belong to a or
to B or to both so in terms of this
picture the union of the two sets would
be this blue set after this reminder
about set theoretic notation now let us
look at the form of the third axiom what
does it say if we have two sets two
events two subsets of the sample space
which are disjoint so here's our sample
space and here are the two sets that
this joint in mathematical terms two
sets being disjoint means that their
intersection has no elements so their
intersection is the empty set and we use
this symbol here to denote the empty set
so if the intersection of two sets is
empty then the probability that the
outcome of the experiment falls in the
union of a and B that is the probability
that the outcome is here
or there is equal to the sum of the
probabilities of these two sets this is
called the additive 'ti axiom so it says
that we can add probabilities of
different sets when those two sets are
disjoint
in some sense we can think of
probability as being one pound of some
substance which is spread over our
sample space and the probability of a is
how much of that substance is sitting on
top of a set a so what this axiom is
saying is that the total amount of that
substance sitting on top of a and and B
is how much is sitting on top of a plus
how much is sitting on top of B and that
is the case whenever the sets a and B
are disjoint from each other the
additive 'ti axiom needs to be refined a
bit we will talk about that a little
later
other than this refinement these three
axioms are the only requirements in
order to have a legitimate probability
model at this point you may ask
shouldn't there be more requirements
shouldn't we for example say that
probabilities cannot be greater than one
yes and no we do not want probabilities
to be larger than one but we do not need
to say it as we will see in the next
segment such a requirement follows from
what we have already said and the same
is true for several other natural
properties of
bilities